Lock em to this video playing Jesus sees
this from the Netherlands right
sometimes I mean I know that this color
combination is the Netherlands but I
wasn't sure if there's something in now
the middle ok so I'm Queens gambit
accepted with a quick Bishop to g4 mmm i
think this this has a name that i forgot
it yeah knight c6 yeah i studied this a
while ago so sometimes played by israeli
grandmaster and theoretical eduardo
hikaru nakamura are to Cogan he was a
second from a camera in i think that the
town memorial he's always this guy cohen
is always and very creative in the
opening okay so this guy is giving me
the c6 porn but i'm not terribly well
coordinated yeah nevertheless i'm
already on a 4 and went all the way to
that I should I should really capture
the problem is of course lurking
position and my development
very quickly played yeah and enter and
interesting maybe just intending to go
Queen to h4 hmm yeah it's not not very
comfortable
Jim to be found
and maybe hey Scott he just has a night
before him III is a terribly slow move I
have very serious doubts about this
position okay I hope it's still
resilient
yeah i know i'm moving this piece again
i'm trying to this was my dear hoping
that this actually keeps the position
closed and this actually knows for me
improving upon structure and maybe I get
in even before he's got a five though
before if I'm filming some bit of a
shame okay let's do that first the rook
is vulnerable one on h1 anyway so v3m
bishop between yeah of course I'd love
to get the bishop on be tuned
when the long diagonal let's put it that
way be three years prolly going a green
be five I have to push a bit too then
rook f7 it's not too great maybe I can
even prepare before complicated and i'm
down to 122 yeah this will be the most
important factor in this game probably
the clock time yeah
yeah I need to return some material him
yeah I probably should have played them
this in some other way now this isn't so
bad be sure before maybe I a Scott
Walker t7 I knocked his happiness a good
move here
I think what could you seven was even
better this is this is not not bad for
black but the other move was maybe even
even stronger
no I don't mind to get rid of the H
point so some helping me nicely
okay this is impossible to calculate
check
check
now I got gotten quite substantially
technol but of course he's got the pawns
check-check taking six
check
look the eight mate as a threat
look d 2g eight rock g2g ate meat it's
not so easy to prevent him checks with
that check check check check time
morning group g1 h 1 meters very very
hard how to defend it just detected I'm
such an idiot he just attacked it I just
need to retreat it and it's it's over
okay but I'm still I'm still good here
Brooke g7 as a big threat yeah of course
the bloody time
now I taste crappy game I just hate this
kind of game I just need to retreat this
book and it's over like resides here
okay it's blitz chess what can you do
just just some other move and it's gone
the King on edge for is just just a joke
I mean somewhere this has just made rook
d 1 h 1 no way is going to prevent that
just plus 4 I just thought this would be
I would be made already but okay plus 4
is take that now maybe add some Mia this
is plus 7 winning check whatever rook t5
is the easiest winning winning this rook
yeah he allowed far too much counter
play was completely unnecessary g6 is
just just terrible but okay it's um it's
a matter of a matter of time of course I
spent far too much time before this made
me check get into this position this is
winning all along for white I just pick
can also take just e6 here check one two
can we get get both hooks into play
check and here this is completely gone
yeah but ok time management is some as a
factor of course it's the kind of game
well with increment you just witness
white but with some death five minutes
it's very tricky alright thanks for
watching